[Music]
if you're like me we're all about this
changing world of tech and lately it's
hard to miss all the hype around
microservices
so let's talk about a way to get ahead
of this revolution with one simple
solution tell us about the latest
innovations coming from the studio we
have program director Raj who you want
she so Raj let's start with an easy one
here what is the goal of IBM micro
service builder and how will it help my
business the primary goal for micro
service builder is to empower companies
on their journey to becoming a cloud
native company that will help them to do
the digital transformation necessary to
be successful in this new marketplace
because everything is changing people
are having most of their interactions
are digital now as opposed to the old
storefront face to face salesperson kind
of a way thanks right so micro Services
is bringing a comprehensive approach to
delivering software which means in a
continuous delivery lifecycle as a user
my expectation is I need response to my
interest quickly right how do I do that
well to fulfill those requirements
enterprises are trying to say well let
me break down what was traditionally a
physical interaction into small chunks
of pieces which can satisfy customer
requirements quickly so that the
customer becomes a loyal customer on my
digital channel since the digital
channel is continuously available it is
my expectation is I'm going to get a
service 24 by 7 yes because nobody wants
to wait right that's right industry is
something like Netflix right Netflix is
never done right because it better not
be better not down next so the idea
behind that is there is there are new
mechanisms new ways of having writing
programs in a way which are called cloud
native and these cloud native
applications bring in the
choice of resiliency from the
infrastructure into your application so
that your application itself is now
intelligent enough to know what should
happen if my back-end collapses that's
how it is always on all those things
coming together how do you bring them
together is what micro service builder
is trying to do Oh fantastic
so how is micro service builder unique
micro service builders approach is a
turnkey approach it's a comprehensive
solution that brings all these five
elements together to give you a smooth
end-to-end user experience from
development all the way to deployment
and then everything in between in terms
of how to run and manage your
infrastructure so it's really helping
them build YES on what they currently
have and providing them freedom IBM
microcell der gives them capability to
connect and extend their enterprise
applications that they have already
worked on they are invested in we ensure
that you are not locked into a single
cloud you can take that application a
containerized application and deploy
them on any cloud either on-premises off
premises or hybrid yes you're all about
trying to help your customer in the way
that they would best benefit love it
absolutely go IBM thank you yeah
you
[Music]